we reject nation it's Greg all there
what's your name I'm Caitlin Caitlin
Nicole foster here from the YouTube
channel big screen books she covers a
lot of movie talk over there trailer
reactions as well a lot of book coverage
type of deal something that I do often
is read a book oh do you well I start
I'm talking at least once a year how do
you feel about a Dwayne the rock you
rock Johnson I love you there's this new
trailer out that some people sent to me
rampage us-versus-them it looks like
he's doing a selfie here I don't think
every selfie of the rock video is are
you sorry for rampage I'm so excited you
ever play the arcade nope
why not lie it oh I probably happens you
crazy you're gonna make in the YouTube
world your paps a lot I've never played
the arcade but I let's get to it and
page him the day shout-out for Cody
Bedell hey what's up everybody I want
you to enjoy my brand new badass trailer
for a pager when I say badass I'm
talking about badass those monsters
don't stop big someone's mutating
animals into postures
dream monster
[Music]
Oh what was that you can't put up the
graphic I'm running for my life come on
dude the world is watching this I'm the
most badass movie star on the planet all
right I got a reputation to protect
now show the other clip for some reason
back got me the most exciting
in-your-face exciting adventure and it
was like self-aware yeah what it was
because I remember the first trailer was
like this looks silly and cheesy and
looked like a lot of fun but it looked
like it was taking itself seriously yeah
and the second trailer was like okay
this is more to the tone I wanted just a
really fun movie and then in this one I
loved the fact that they made fun of
that agency like the Transformers movies
or whatever or even the Pacific Rim in
some capacity you're like I'm going to
see the big giant things like smash
the better make willing to make fun of
that they have a human character and he
feels like it really do anything that
was such a nice surprise if the movie
has that level of self-awareness of it
that makes me even more excited for
because this is more of the kind of rock
that I'm into and the more like the fun
self-aware type what's that new one
skyscraper that's not my kind of flavor
of the rock but it is something like
this where it's this fun that is packed
and fun like this this looks like just a
fun ass monster romp fest and and I feel
like the rock is probably just having a
blast making it really that was a
brilliant marketing man that marketing
got me so nature the day shout-out for
Cody Bedell Cody my friend the reason
I'm giving you a shout out today is
because you don't really talk to us on
patreon almost everyone we talked to on
patreon talks to us it's hard to get a
message back from you that makes me kind
of want to go on a rampage makes me whoa
and John's going on a rampage to the
light that's feelings towards you not
replying back to us when we're just
trying to get to know you so we could
give you a more detailed attention
filled shout out now you're making our
job hard Cody what is it man why do you
want to get my temper out there Katelyn
see my temper super-sexy temper rampage
yeah I hold up and I sweat my hair gets
yeah I don't know why she thought was
actually I think everyone else thinks
it's disgusting but I appreciate the
compliment I hop around the corner
Katelyn and Nicole talk to us a little
bit more man miss you bud I miss you
more if I knew you better thanks for
supporting the patreon page and thanks
for supporting the channel
either way we accept the support you're
great
subscribe to the real rejects people
click that notification bell check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions over there as well as weekly
video response q and A's and most
importantly make sure to check out
foster
you have like three names are like like
three first name make sure to check
around big screen books a lot of great
videos on there some awesome reactions
as well a lot of great movie reviews if
you're into books she's your girl to go
check out go follow her